yeah they are deeply disturbing
allegations and they center on john yems
the manager here one of the most
outspoken characters in lower league
football in this country who has now
been suspended by crawley town football
club suspended 11 days ago based on what
the owners of this club new american
investors said were serious and credible
allegations now the details of those
allegations have now come to light seven
players
have gone to the professional
footballers association to register
complaints about alleged racist behavior
from john yems and
those include deeply offensive and
racist names being used to players from
ethnically diverse backgrounds and also
this notion of segregation asking white
players and those from different
backgrounds to change in different rooms
and that is something that
is is at the center of this and we have
spoken to one former player here at
crawley town who played under john yems
for a couple of seasons who has said
that he fully recognizes those behaviors
and
it really chimes with his experience of
playing
for this football club and we know that
there are now three investigations
ongoing one
from the club itself one from the
football association who say they are
taking this extremely seriously and one
from the pfa that organization that
represents footballers who the
footballers first went to they're being
offered support and counselling we are
told last night here at the home stadium
there was a fans forum event that was
pre-planned and was due to be streamed
on youtube to a wider audience but that
stream was cut half an hour or so before
the start of the meeting and fans were
told that they would not be able to ask
questions about the situation involving
their suspended manager john yems and it
was pretty limited in what the owners
could tell them um they said that there
is an investigation ongoing and that
they will try to establish the truth
afterwards we spoke to a few of the
season ticket holders who were leaving
that forum as to their view as to the
investigations that are underway here at
crawley town and the importance of
establishing the truth as quickly as
possible
you can't prejudice the situation one
way or the other investigation is going
on and we'll find out in due course
what's
what occurs i guess how do you feel
about it all
well
a bit a little bit shocked i guess but
it is what it is you know nothing that
uh we can do we can just we
will be here watching the
start of the new season and
whether it's the current manager or a
new manager who knows we now have to
wait we have to it has to be
investigated and we wait for facts and
evidence
i don't speculate
and
as long as in due process can they get
through it as quickly as possible
and let's see what the truth is then
when we know the truth
we can make the right moves
we know that those three separate
investigations are still ongoing and
haven't yet reached any conclusions and
understanding john yemez's side
of his account of what has been going on
here will be crucial
part of that investigation we have made
repeated attempts to contact mr yems to
offer him the chance to respond to the
allegations and as yet he has not
responded to that and the club have also
declined requests
for interview the
season will finish for crawley town next
weekend a wet and away fixture at oldham
athletic who are already relegated they
are 12th at the moment in league two and
the younger brother of ashley young the
former england player louis young is now
in charge of first team affairs while
the investigations around the racism
allegations here at crawley continue